what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to my channel the
cosmic wonder it seems like our dry
spell of marvel content
is over for many many months there we
weren't really getting any mcu content
but over the past couple of weeks we
have been swarmed
with new information we've had the
she-hulk casting miss marvel got its
directors we got a trailer for one
division and now we have
official news about a new disney plus
series
it looks like sam jackson is returning
to the mcu reprising his role as the one
and only nick fury today variety
reported that marvel studios is
officially developing a new disney plus
series that is going to star sam jackson
as nick fury
and here's variety's report samuel l
jackson is set to reprise the role of
nick fury in a new marvel series
currently
in development at disney plus so this
show is already in development marvel
studios has already been working on this
project
so we really have no idea how long
marvel studios has been working on this
but it's most likely going to come in
marvel's phase 5.
now the report from variety goes on to
say that the plot details of the show
are being kept under wraps
and that's typical marvel studios
fashion but we can deduct what we expect
the show to be
now the last time that we saw nick fury
was in the post-credits scene of
spider-man far from home
and he was aboard a ship in space with a
bunch of scroll
now marvel kind of changed to the scroll
r in the mcu compared to the comics in
the comics they're actually the bad guys
but as captain marvel revealed and as
spider-man far from home's post credit
scene revealed they're good they're on
our side at least
most of them are so what exactly is this
spaceship in space that nick fury is on
with all of these scroll
well this is widely believed and it
makes the most sense to be swords
headquarters located in space called
the peak now sword stands for sentient
world observation and response
department and it's the counterpart to
shield shield's job is to handle earthly
threats and sword's job is to handle
extraterrestrial threats which is why
their headquarters is located in space
but nick fury is there in the
headquarters in space
so what role is nick fury going to play
with
sword well as we all probably assume
he's most likely going to be
in charge instead of shield now he's
moved on to sword it's very clear after
avengers in game and after the infinity
saga in its entirety that there are many
extraterrestrial threats out there that
could potentially come and harm earth
so after infinity war where nick fury
got snapped along with maria hill and
after avengers end game it looks like
nick fury wants to focus
a little bit more towards those
extraterrestrial threats after all no
human
on earth has the ability on his own to
wipe out half of the universe
so over this past year there have been
many different rumors that agents of
sword could be developing
and since this show is going to star
samuel l jackson as nick fury as the
main character and he's working with
sword and he's most likely going to be
the head of sword
this could be an agent of sword show now
that may not be the official title but
that's essentially what it's looking
like we're going to get
and again right now we don't know the
plot but some insiders are saying that
they're hearing it could be a
secret invasion plot which is the
perfect job for
sword so marvel is really up to a lot
right now developing series that we
didn't even know were in the works so if
you want to stay up to date on all of
these disney plus series and everything
in the mcu be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out
don't forget to leave a like and let me
know down below in the comments what you
think about this new disney plus series
starring
nick fury and let me know what you would
like to see out of this tv show would
you like to see
the secret invasion storyline let me
know down below and don't forget to
follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof